now i had some reports from people who feel
very weak when they drink too much water
especially when they're doing fasting and i
want to talk about why that is it's basically
a deficiency of sodium a person is going to feel
very weak if they don't consume enough salt and
i recommend sea salt so there's all sorts of
things that can make you deficient with sodium
number one not consuming enough sea salt and
of course when you're fasting you're usually
not consuming anything except water and the
more water you drink the more you dilute
the minerals including salt and sodium so the
combination of drinking more water when you're
fasting is a bad combination you always want to
consume sea salt if you're fasting our bodies need
minimally three and a half to four to five grams
of sodium that's roughly between a teaspoon and
a half to two teaspoons of sea salt every single
day also if you're doing low carb you're going to
require more salt than if you're doing higher
amounts of carbohydrate that's simply because
when you're in a high carb diet you're going to
retain more salt than when you're in a low carb
diet now the other thing that can create a sodium
deficiency is consuming large amounts of potassium
so if you're doing electrolyte with a lot of
potassium and you're not doing enough sea salt
that can throw you off too especially if you're
doing all these other things like fasting so don't
forget about the sea salt now the more stress
you go through the more salt you're going to need
because when you're pumping a lot of cortisol you
lose sodium salt is needed as a part of the stress
response now of course if it's hot outside it's
summer and you're sweating and you're exercising
you're definitely going to need more salt and if
you're on a diuretic or an antidepressant you're
going to need more sodium if there's liver damage
if you have hepatitis or you have a fatty liver
or you have cirrhosis or you have kidney damage
because you're a diabetic you're going to need
more sodium which is interesting because a lot
of times you're told to avoid salt if you have
those conditions and lastly you can lose salt
if you have diarrhea or you're vomiting so these
are all factors to consider if you're feeling
weak you could be deficient in sodium one quick
way to find out is just to start consuming more
salt and see if you feel stronger so if you're
enjoying my content which i hope you are and
you're applying this knowledge to your health
and you have a success i'd really appreciate you
sharing your success story so click the link down
below to my website where you can upload your
success story so you can help inspire others